Welcome back everyone this going to be my
new DC Fandome trailer for the Batman and
the other DC movies they'll be releasing footage
for.
There's a couple new scenes from all the different
movies in this.
So I'll explain what's going on.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs obviously is
going to be crazy this weekend.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all those videos of course
will be doing videos for all the trailers
they release it is going to be trailer city
in a couple days if you have no idea what's
going on DC Fandome is coming this Saturday
and they release this trailer.
Just to hype up all the other trailers are
dropping is a trailer for a bunch of trailers
mostly for the Batman trailer in a couple
the other upcoming movies like the flash movie,
which also has two other versions of Batman
the black Adam trailer in a bunch of early
footage for everything else within this they
did include some new teasers with brand-new
footage.
They haven't released before, so I'll talk
about that and since the last Batman trailer
we've learned a lot more about what's going
on with Matt Reeves Batman universe in their
overall plans for the future of Batman in
the DC movies.
Or at least a version of Batman the DC movies.
Because now we do have three versions of Batman
running around in the movies will start with
the Batman stuff.
Just because that sort of like the crown jewel
of DC Fandome this year and then I'll talk
about the new footage and Easter eggs for
the other movies like the black Adam footage
in some of the other flash movie footage in
here is just a little more footage of Robert
pattinson's Batman Catwoman the Riddler the
Batmobile mixed with some footage from the
trailer that we saw last year.
And on top of that you may have also noticed
some small changes in the older footage.
If you watched a lot of trailers for a lot
of different movies different studios you
probably notice the between the first teasers
in the last trailers for movies things like
the color correction the special-effects the
way they frame shots all changes a little
bit so that sometimes you think that you're
looking at different footage.
Even though they use the same footage a lot
of trailers the cool thing about the last
Batman trailer we got last year is that when
they released it Matt Reeves had only been
filming the movie for a couple weeks legit
released a long asked teaser trailer and they'd
only been filming for a couple weeks in a
most of that footage was only from like 20%
of the movie will be a pretty good idea for
what the story is the tone and where Matt
Reeves is taking this Robert pattinson version
of Batman is being referred to is more of
a Batman horror movie than we've ever seen
before.
Not a legit horror movie like a Halloween
movies like Nella slasher flick just more
horror elements in a more horror bend on the
material than say Christopher Nolan's Batman
dark knight movies.
But this new Batman movie borrows a lot of
inspiration for the long Halloween story.
It seems like is set around the hollowing
holiday because of all the hollowing costumes
for the other Justice league characters like
this is Superman hollowing costume walking
around in the footage switches lends itself
to a little bit more the heightened horror
elements the you see around the hollowing
holiday is not a copy paste version of the
long Halloween story just borrowing some inspiration
from that some elements and is using the Riddler
to sort of set up this first movie in a trilogy
was sort of the zodiac type of twist on the
character like the David Fincher zodiac version
of the Riddler the whole murder mystery of
it all mixed with the darker scarier take
on the Batman mythos it is funny that I make
the zodiac comparison.
Because if you been watching the news this
past week, they actually just revealed the
true identity of the real world zodiac killer
that that movie was based on like legit they
just found out who he was a couple years after
the David Fincher movie came out so the real
zodiac killer would've been able to watch
the movie that was done about him.
But as you can see from all the footage Matt
Reeves just going with the darker scarier
take on the Batman mythos and the other really
big change that Matt Reeves has said that
he's done with his version of this new Batman
universities building is to put this movie
earlier in Batman's career but not doing a
Batman origin story.
That's what he's doing is year to Batman in
one of the big reasons why he chose to do
it that way is so they could also do origin
stories for most of his bigger rogues gallery
of villains like Catwoman.
Even though she's not really a villain technically
Penguin Riddler.
Even the new version of the Joker in the sequels
that he'll eventually pry workup to.
So yes, it's all about doing a darker world's
greatest detective style Batman murder mystery
thriller movie Neo Nomar style really is about
leaning hard into the villains in a way the
Batman movies haven't done in a while.
Like Matt Reeves legit said that he was just
as excited to do a movie about Batman villains.
As he was to do a movie about Batman himself,
the villains are often some of the most if
not the most exciting part of the movie for
me throne shall be incredible somewhat I wanted
to do was.
I wanted to see a Batman that was not an origin
tale that was sort of in his early days.
That meant that a lot of the characters who
are the rogues gallery characters are in their
origins in a way, and so we have a Selena
Kyle who's not yet Catwoman we got a lot of
Batman villains during the Christopher Nolan
dark knight movies.
But he didn't focus on them quite as much
as it sounds like Matt Reeves is focusing
on the villains.
In fact they've also confirmed 2 spinoff series
from the Batman movie for HBO you've heard
about at least one of them.
Maybe the other two.
No release dates for either of them yet, but
the first one is the Gotham city PD series
that they talked about a long time ago, it
sounds like that is actually now turned into
more of an Arkham asylum series with the Gotham
PD and Gordon just being a huge part of it.
Like I said Matt Reeves leaning harder into
the villains is much easier to do that when
you taken Arkham spin on a TV series, the
second Batman movie spinoff that you probably
just heard about is the full-blown Penguin
series for Colin Farrell's Penguin who said
that he's barely in this first new Batman
movie and probably won't be a big character
till the sequel so don't be surprised if they
do other HBO series for more of the Batman
villains between Batman movie sequels in this
new trilogy in the next several years.
But Robert pattinson is supposed to be the
new main version of Batman in the movies.
The way that they view it at Warner Bros.,
but because the rolling full multiverse with
the DC movies using the flash movie and they're
bringing back both Ben Affleck's Batman from
the main Justice league earth and Michael
Keaton's Batman from earth 89 or whichever
earth you want to call his earth from the
Tim Burton Batman movies.
Robert pattinson's Batman isn't going to be
the big crossover Batman of the other DC movies
at least right away Matt Reeves made it sound
like he just wanted to do his own thing in
his own corner the multiverse for at least
right now in that was the reason why they
wanted to put it on earth to which is where
it's supposed to be taking place.
Maybe they'll be some Easter eggs or reference
for his Batman during the flash movie when
the flashes traveling the multiverse.
There is a little bit of flash movie footage
in this there can be releasing a teaser trailer
in some behind-the-scenes for if you remember
there was a leak to flash movie promo from
earlier this year with a whole bunch of concept
footage in details about what's actually happening
in the movie with the scenes.
It showed Ezra Miller flash inside Michael
Keaton's back cave.
It showed another ministry character that
they kept blurring out with spoiler warnings.
I believe that's because the character is
supposed to be the secret villain of the movie
in a dark version of the flash.
But it's gonna be like dark flash versus Ezra
Miller flash instead of the villain being
straight up he'll bar Thon reverse flash because
are doing the flashpoint inspired story if
he saw the new previews they released of all
the different logos this logo the flash symbol
spray painted red and yellow over one of Michael
Keaton's Batman suit.
I believe is supposed to represent his dark
flash character in there's also supposed to
be the black Adam trailer with actual footage
from the movie.
There couple scenes of him in his costume
in this trailer here.
This is basically what he looks like.
But they kind of cut them off at the shoulders
here.
This is what the fool costume looks like behind-the-scenes
this is also Hawkman's costume looks familiar.
This is a first look at cyclone in her costume
and then this is obviously Pierce Brosnan
he's playing their doctor fate of the DCEU
I'm assuming we'll see him in his costume
in that teaser trailer they release, but they're
using the black Adam movie to introduce the
DCEU justice society, so we might actually
also get a spinoff for their team in the future
as well.
They do have a version of the justice society
on the stargirl TV series featuring Jon Wesley
Shipp's Jay Garrick I'm also kind of hoping
that they feature Jon Wesley ship as some
character some cameo scene inside the flash
movie.
It will be a bummer if he's not lease in there
somewhere also probably some sort of cameo
scene or some sort of reference to grant Guston's
flash from the Arrowverse because the big
Justice league crossover in a crisis on infinite
earths and on the other side of the black
Adam coin.
They are supposed to release some sort of
new shazam two teaser trailer they released
one a couple months ago and I did a video
for so a link that blown the description.
But it was just a comedic clip of him showing
up inside their living room to highlight the
brand-new costume since he got full-blown
redesign costumes that look way better and
they reveal that they change the way they're
doing the Mary marvel character, because now
the actors who plays the real version of Barry
is old enough in the right size to play the
superhero version of Mary marvel when her
powers are activated.
But this is really just scratching the surface
in terms of the big trailers, they'll be releasing
Filby of peacemaker trailer for the HBO series.
Probably an official release date for that
to trailers for most of the other TV shows
and maybe some kind of early preview for that
Green Lantern HBO series because it is been
a hot minute since they've revealed any more
information about that.
But if you have any big questions or requests
for the videos that I do for all the stuff.
Just let me know in the comments below and
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any those trailers.
Everyone click here for that brand-new marvel
daredevil announcement about him coming back
and click here for my brand-new eternal Eternals
trailer video and Easter eggs that you so
much for watching everyone stay safe and I'll
see you guys next one!